hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday March 2nd 2020 what's going
on how are you this is today is my 28th
anniversary of being a stand-up comedian
Oh young Billy bar way back in the day
came out with this big giant red [ __ ]
afro got on stage and nixed comedy stop
at the Emerson College [ __ ] comedy
night talent night at whatever new
talent night I didn't win as usual I
didn't win I can't think of a better way
to [ __ ] celebrate my 28th anniversary
which really isn't a big one it's 25 or
30 I would think would be a big one than
to be with a longtime friend it hasn't
been a guest on the show for a long time
but wonderful they always they always
decked out with his latest pair of
[ __ ] Jordans mr. Paul virzi what's
going on it's up man who those are some
shiny ass [ __ ] doesn't like tuxedo
[ __ ] shiny black things would you
want what number are those these are
actually 70 toes in 1996 Jordan 11s and
Michael Jordan's personal favorites to
wear when he played because of the
support these are these are actually his
all time if you ask Michael Jordan with
his favorite sauce no I will do that
next time I see ya walking through an
airport on his way to a private jet
[Laughter]
he'll dude how much did he crush it at
Kobe's memorial crushed it it was great
crushed it absolutely joke with the the
meme he goes I told my wife I'm not
gonna cry go can I just gonna have to
see this meme for the next three or four
years
isn't that funny that's rushed like he
could stand up crushed I know I just
think it's it's so funny that like that
you know people who can't even [ __ ]
you know catch a frisbee can actually
annoy the greatest basketball player of
all time yeah yeah who the [ __ ] are
these [ __ ] they have a [ __ ] hit a
foul shot directly you're giving me [ __ ]
everybody cries yeah
yeah what are you gonna do but that was
a no happy anniversary 28 years of doing
stand-up I didn't when I first met you
in oh five you were that was Wow
I was 13 years in that wasn't 11 years
ago Bo the Paul that was 15 years ago
I'd be 15 years in November so it's been
forged I've known you for 14 years for
14 years and you've probably had
probably 14,000 different pairs of
[ __ ] Jordans yeah you know what's
that common they're always brand new
what not yeah I don't I don't like to
wear them a lot you know I don't like to
wear them on social occasion yeah but
it's like you're breaking out you find
China one of these days I'm gonna have
you and Yanis who else is a big sneaker
head on here and I just want to [ __ ]
I want you guys to make fun of me my dad
[ __ ] jeans and [ __ ] you know the
theory I have always have you're one of
those guys where it's like you look like
you just work casual and then you show
up and surprise with just like like last
night you had I saw you last night you
had those Jordan one gray and blacks
that go with you know what that was this
Pete Davidson got me those when I did
his movie last summer that's the only
reason why no but I remember one time we
were working together when I opened for
you long time ago I know before you came
a [ __ ] headliner in their own right I
went out Club well we're trying thanks
but no by the way were you gonna be oh
dude it's like the dates cuz I got I got
a big date I got a plug too good all
right so do you got off this weekend
coming up guys I'm gonna be at levity
live March 5th through great love great
club great Club it's it's it is in a
mall and it's one of those where you go
and then you walk in and it's like
jacked up and beautiful and everybody
does come out great food great club come
out I'm also gonna be through the 8th my
5th through the asy you becoming a
monster dude you're getting all those
reps in getting up thank you and and I'm
guess where I'm gonna be June 27th my
first theater date guys the Wilbur
theater in Boston a [ __ ] Paul the Wilbur
theater Rose thrown up where I actually
when I couldn't be with you on your
whole run there but we did a bunch there
I was also a salvo Cano for my practical
jokers there and I told people I'm gonna
be out June 17th but if you're in the
Boston area
one show Saturday June 27th and I'm
gonna be in Baltimore Salt Lake City in
Cincinnati all on Palmers EECOM but this
weekend March 5th through the 8th get
tickets June 27th Wilbur and for all the
other dates like I said I have
Cincinnati Baltimore and Salt Lake City
all on Palmers even go inside and bindus
I haven't been to Utah my career I'm
banned forever yeah it's fun man those
people are fun it's great day that's one
of those cities you know you know it's
one of those states it's just an easy
one to make fun of because everybody
think oh these religious would be I'm
not doing okay yeah yeah why would you
do that that's like only Houston making
fun of fact everybody's fat out there
which is something I do every time I
just can't let it go the fact that they
won back-to-back years like how
difficult that's a dynasty with fat
people because usually the people that
put you over the top are dead a year
later so it's like losing them to
free-agency except they die yeah people
in the south know how to eat though dude
like I went down there they do I mean
they pay a price you know what they are
they're like old wrestlers and old
football players where they love the
game and now their bodies paid for it
you know like CTE and [ __ ] they got like
[ __ ] clogged arteries oh dude yeah
they just blown out from wait they're
just limping around they're just fat and
Houston they were just they had this
nachos and it was just like that's
nachos man and I was like how you make
natural no but it was on a platter dude
like it wasn't like you know New York
nachos the [ __ ] pig in the middle of
it with an apple in its mouth
yeah yes the chips down here we let him
sit out in the Sun for extra day so
they're strong enough to get that swine
meat off the middle but you know what
they own it like you could be like you
guys eat like animals down here they're
black dad's rest are clapping yeah they
don't care they don't give they don't
care let it drive trucks Wisconsin
people are animals and I've got rocks
Paul so they can get in the [ __ ]
vehicle they workout is stepping up into
it but once they came out with that
thing where they had let you know that
electric step there you open the door
and it just kind of comes down yeah that
was four people down south wheels are
still on the ground but you see the
whole truck moves the rest of the truck
moves is a guy go
to get in dude speaking of that me and
Bart Nick Joe bartnik our buddy we were
walking in Pasadena and there was a
giant dude I swear there was a giant dog
in the back of this rav4 and it was and
it they won't only had it like this and
it was going woo and dude the car what
do you like this so people like like a
widow didn't want people to like make
eye contact with it and the windows were
really tinted but it was just a little
bit so the dog had air but you can see
the silhouette of the dog was gigantic
right it was going through roof and the
whole seat it look like people were like
[ __ ] in the back I never dude I never
saw a truck sway from a dog bark just
barking and it was like roof and joy
Bartek know Bart nixb barn eggs big
upper body and I just started laughing
apart it's like dude this thing made the
truck go like this back and forth it was
off when you described that was
picturing that you know that vague
picture of the Loch Ness monster know do
like there are some dogs in my
neighborhood I don't know what it's like
out here I mean I'm sure it's the same
but where I'm I'm up in the [ __ ] like or
there's like farms where you have to
have your dog fenced in like your dog
has to be fenced in the house and not
alone we'll get it
mountain lions and packs of coyotes and
[ __ ] and dude this there's like a couple
of dogs that when you go by with my dog
we know to just take another coyotes are
like be level like headliners you know
it means being headliners like they're
not quite wolves coyotes get confident
with more with more of them well there's
always two of what wolves fight in packs
too but there's always [ __ ] two of
them and but you know what they don't
really [ __ ] with pea they're gonna be
like super hungry
to [ __ ] with an adult as far as I know
like I've seen cuz I cuz I looked it up
cuz we got we got a lot in this area and
I was just like all right you know thank
you hit like late at night you'll just
you'll hear some little dogs yeah
Jesus Christ what the [ __ ] is that is
like yeah you know either saw a coyote
or he's getting eaten by oh they sound
like they're screaming but somebody told
me they go when you see one it's scared
and wants nothing to do with you said if
you see two or three and they continue
coming it says
get get the kids inside yeah I've never
seen that they usually this is like two
they're like they're like they're like
sherry looking they look like sick they
look like grey sick Shepherds I know but
do they have a look wild animals all
have that look
I was joke it's like a prostitute yeah a
prostitute looks at you that's that's
the real deal
she will [ __ ] you that's there's no joke
well the fast balls yes you still
nothing the fast ball spot I know dude I
don't know dude I think she's I think
she's into me you're like dude she there
was no bag we were at a football oh I
know people don't even people do all I
have to tell this one story we're know
we're at a football game and we go out
over there we what we open a Tampa Tampa
Bay Buccaneers last one I needed to go
to yes yeah and me you Bartnik Burke
we're all out there and there was a
blonde lady and she's gonna guys come
here by herself by herself
and she was guys can you help me I lost
my bag like somewhere in the purse my
purse like over here and we're like
where and she like pointed to this like
little strip of grass and bushes and I'm
like really looking for looking for it
and then she like was like talking and I
I told it see she before whatever she
went through she was gorgeous
but she was looking road-weary oh no she
look whether did she was looking like
I'm ones yeah Grogan had like that the
[ __ ] neck brace sewed into the top of
his jersey she was like in that yeah
part of her career as a beautiful woman
and and she was like saying nice things
and act to me and I and I said to these
guys I know dude she's just chick I
think she's into me she's throwing
fastballs chicks throwing nothing but
fast balls over here more like Paul
she's a hooker laughter I know you were
trying to do anything you were saying
they would like five other guys who just
is your egos just like hey I still got
it this chick thinks I'm beautiful just
throw another my fastball Paul she's a
[ __ ] hooker you guys just looked at
each other left and go she's a hooker
and I don't know she's not how funny is
it like I just totally got caught look I
didn't realize your ego you wanted you
wanted to still be good-looking I was
just like I think she's into it so funny
um I've been there we've all [ __ ]
been there where was just like you think
it you know what happened today like my
[ __ ] egos that I went to a [ __ ]
farmers market and this woman I had no
idea she was she goes hey
and I immediately thought she recognized
me from TV and she was talking to
somebody behind me and I almost said
hello to her like I know I know I'm the
guy who does the [ __ ] jokes that's so
fun like you I come down here to get my
celery and she wasn't even talking to me
he's just one and it all went on in my
head my I forgot to tell Mia cuz Nia
would have laughed her ass off dude that
is so funny because like for the first
time ever ever this year somebody's like
in front of my wife and it took a long
time one time my wife wasn't there two
people came up to me at the same place
do to you Paul versus anyway dude I'm a
huge fan I saw you in this place and I'm
like where's my wife right so one time
me and Stacey are sitting there guy
interrupts us with her friends there and
he goes - dude I saw you in Connecticut
- and like everybody and I like I had
that moment something like a month after
that I walked into a place and two
people just looked at me and I in my
mind I'm like they recognize there's
like nobody recognizes you you have
17,000 followers
nobody recognized you nobody to where
you have nobody no dude I gotta tell I
gotta tell me I gotta tell your
listeners a story because this is one of
my favorite this is might be actually
one of my favorite moments with you and
then comedy interrupted it so here's
what here's this story I don't know if
you've ever mentioned him so I had the
pleasure the first picture first major
motion picture I was a part of is this
the guy we thought no no no you don't
know this Oh first major motion picture
I'm a part of is a Judd Apatow Pete
Davidson thing with you and unbeknownst
to me me and you were on it you know
together which was a very nice thing
right the first time I take part in
something and I go there the first day
and it was when you guys were doing the
camera stuff and I had to do all these
pictures for the movie and I see you
stand standing there and you see you got
you got your look and I got my look and
I got my mustache so we're taking
pictures and everyone's there and you
were like I'm gonna be done at five
o'clock I go out they're gonna be done
around 5:30 you go I'll wait for you so
you waited for me to take pictures and
you just go I go dude you want to go
this is like a great day let's go get
some Italian food right so so you go
yeah you go you know what I'm hungry to
something you know what you know what I
go oh no but so I go I'm hungry too you
know I could go
for a nice glass of red I could go for a
nice glass of red and let's get
something you go let's do it and we're
walking and we go and we sit in this
nice Italian restaurant bills across
from me big deal from me just because
I'm being a part of something I've done
sketches and Funny or Die [ __ ] never
never got an opportunity to take part in
something like this and we're sitting
there and you said something you go dude
I can't believe like you're on this
thing and you're a part of this thing
that's so awesome
and we're having this meal so I get veal
and penne I forgot what you had you
write the chicken palm you had the
chicken parm side of pasta with
spaghetti so it's a sign up I own a
marinara with marinara and I have my
wine and we're just talking and we were
dressed up a hood and Bill's going
through I can't believe we're on that
together that's so cool man it's just
such a great and we're having this
moment and it's like you being like kind
of a you've been like a mentor to me all
this stuff and as we're talking bills
hand slips off of his silverware
he literally punched a plate of red
marinara sauce
not only it splatters on my face on my
polo shirt but the miracle was like the
law of physics were defined because it
was on the wall behind you and your face
dude it look like we both got shot in
the back something next right next to
it's got their [ __ ] brains blown out
what happened was I was cutting the
chicken and it just got I was pushing
down too hard and I hit the plate and
the knife just slid and the way my hand
was I just I like literally punched this
cutlet with such for like it was like
sledge splatter was almost like somebody
slipping down the stairs but you did it
with your hand and you punched a bull
dude it was but it was behind you on my
face it was shocking like neither one of
us said anything for like a second and a
half
I never then I was just like oh I got
embarrassed like I never saw you like
you were borderline blushing and then
the waiter kind of looked over I didn't
say anything then we started laughing
you're like dude I'm so sorry got a polo
Joe I said I can't believe I just did
that you were in shock I didn't Gorge
just Paul versi tracksuit no it was like
something you know is white it was
something like jelly white yeah you know
you Italian you don't just go white you
just go like Jesus is showing up white
for the love of God I don't know how the
[ __ ] bladder got behind your head
it was still to this day I remember see
it was behind your ear on my head no it
outlined my head my face stopped the
other [ __ ] and the waiter came over he
was cool but even he was kind of like
what happened here oh dude it's one of
my favorite things ever because we were
just having a moment and then you just
plunged sauce
I actually was upset that there wasn't
more people there that we knew to see
that oh hey what did I mean I would
first of all I never would have heard
the end you know I thought you want to
talk about that time you know we try to
have a moment we would I've no I told
this story before we were standing
outside that [ __ ] hotel we did some
gig up in Maine
Wolverine oh you just blew it dude
because he came out and we thought he
was he thought he was dressed as Elvis
but he was fat and turned out he was
dressed as Wolverine like I thought he
was an Elvis impersonator smoking cigars
and then you go he looks awesome that
guy looks cool yeah and I thought I
thought he looked like [ __ ] I thought
he was an Elvis impersonator nah I
looked him closest oh [ __ ] he's supposed
to be Wolverine yeah they look like
Elvis when he was all [ __ ] on pills so
we was standing he was smoking a stick
and he was cool as [ __ ] and we're in the
middle of telling a story and he just
he's telling a story and just [ __ ]
ripped farted like he farted like he
note like like we were his kids and we
were in his house I never broke the
story he was just telling it in [ __ ]
bla bla bla bla anything he did he kept
trying to impersonate was there it's
just like Oh [ __ ] windy wet [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] I just kept going and
I [ __ ] left you cuz I turned around I
turned around and left you with him dude
you turned around like a fifth grader
who like a fifth grader [ __ ] around
in the back of class and you just
started laughing I've known you 14 years
I've never farted in front of you like
that this guy who's been outside this
guy just ripped ass and then just kept
talking and Bill you turned around and
walked away and we went from this guy
being cool to get him the [ __ ] out of
here do you remember well look what get
this guy [ __ ] I didn't because I
couldn't regain my composure you're sick
106 it was you know when you when you
want to laugh as hard as you ever laugh
but you can't makes you go into like
almost like hyperventilating that's what
was happening and I was for some reason
I don't know why I was so concerned he
didn't give a [ __ ] I should just laughed
it's like do did you just [ __ ] what
was that worried what was he gonna do
throw an Elvis karate I would see that
comfortable doing that with two
strangers yeah well I mean it wasn't
like a like a slipped one he was one of
those guys where it's like hey there's
no ladies here and we're outside that it
was a very old school yeah like yeah
[ __ ] like he just didn't give her he
was he very comfortable with himself
yeah was he you know it was you know
like a wife beater was he in like a
weird wasn't he like a weird you like an
open button down with like a wife beater
was he one of those like hairy it was
one of the the the Wolverine outfits it
was like yet he had the mutton chops
that's what [ __ ] me up we came out of
yet the job yet the pompadour and the
[ __ ] thing and I was thinking all
[ __ ] he's getting gonna be like you know
he looks like a cab a B I never loved
you
others start singing some Elvis [ __ ] and
yeah yeah he did look like a character
speaking of characters congratulations
on being in last season's mandalorian my
wife was like sick she doesn't like Star
Wars and she saw it you were like I'm
sorry bad ass thing it's funny cuz you
don't seem like you know you don't seem
like you and that would be like me and
Harry be like a Star Wars fan on ESPN
like me and Harry Potter I know there's
no Italian wizards I have no no that's
dope though man
that's dope to be a part of that was it
fun yeah it is I've always I was kind of
telling somebody the other day like when
I go onto a shoot yeah I have to get it
takes me a minute to get into that
mindset just because there's a comedian
you have such freedom I mean whatever
the [ __ ] I want whenever I want I go
onstage I say whatever I want it works
or it doesn't I plow ahead I don't have
to do it again and then you get into
that thing and then like okay your call
time is this right lunch is here we need
you here for this and stuff so like the
first three days I'm like a [ __ ] cat
on a leash like just for like I can't
[ __ ] handle it yeah and then it's
like you say something then the script
person comes over it's actually like
paging mr. Herman mr. Herman yeah you
said mr. Herman paging Herman I mean
just for half a second like well it
gives a [ __ ] what I said yeah that's
right I'm doing this so it takes me like
three days I have my little meltdown my
little hissy fit of like why does it
take [ __ ] 90 million hours to
do this [ __ ] and then after like three
days then I settle into it then I just
have the time of my life I mean I really
have a good time and really appreciate
you know getting the gig and all that
but the first three days I don't think I
say anything when I'm on set yeah it's
just like I am in in between my ears
going like I could just be at the
[ __ ] movies right now and I could
tonight go out and do a [ __ ] joke and I
would be done and I would have enough
money for my cornflakes in the morning
pay my mortgage yadda yadda yadda but do
you feel like it's something like were
you like let's just say like you get you
get booked in a Star Wars thing like wow
this doesn't feel like something I would
do but then when you do it you're like
holy [ __ ] that was dopest [ __ ] like do
you like know everything that I've done
is it takes three days but first three
days okay got it and then about three
days in you're on average you'll be
about 36 hours into doing it yeah at
that point you know people on set you're
[ __ ] around and all I do is just bust
balls and just act like an idiot the
entire time or else I will go low or
else I will [ __ ] go insane so when
I'm on there not in a bad way
I just [ __ ] sit there I don't know
you ignore the 20-year low - I think I
think part of it is fear I think that's
your thing and you're projecting it onto
me so let's talk about your fear of
being on set well no why does a comic
have fear when it's just like what they
gonna fight and then you can go what
what go back to what not sitting in a
[ __ ] trailer waiting to be a police
officer
I don't think fear like that I think I
our fight or whatever the [ __ ] it is I'm
doing them this way I don't know if it's
fear like that I think it's like just
being out of your comfort zone doing
something that you really haven't done
especially if like let's say you were
type cattle yeah early on yeah are you
like if you're typecast or like let's
say you're always the copy I don't get
your who gives a [ __ ] I joked that I was
playing a copper too but I should I'm
not [ __ ] Daniel day-lewis and I look
like a cop and a fireman so like what
the [ __ ] it's like in these [ __ ]
[ __ ] out here who sit there and
[ __ ] that did typecast it yeah you look
like you drive an ice-cream truck right
so if you want to go against type yeah
write something and put your own [ __ ]
money up against ya to sit there and
think that some [ __ ] guy with this
house in the hills yeah he's gonna roll
the dice on your fat [ __ ] ass yeah
or your weird-looking thing on me a bald
redheaded guy it's not their job that
job is not to take those kinds of I'll
go with Brad Pitt over you for that role
yeah if you don't mind you don't mind I
like the life that I [ __ ] earned
because there is a big thing somebody
came home my wife you skimmer okay there
is this thing that people have just a
notch and I had it for a long time just
now I still do like people would like
just a resentment to rich people that
they automatically is mince that they
[ __ ] people over and yeah and I've found
as I gone up that you know so many
people that I've met especially in this
business are self-made men and women and
they're really cool and [ __ ] funny as
hell dude I met this guy one time I did
a private gig
it's a [ __ ] weird one because it was
out here and it was with that weird
combination of super rich and super
liberal so you don't you don't know up
is down black as Y you don't know where
the [ __ ] the room is yeah it's like
they're [ __ ] bleeding heart is
they're sitting there eating like
endangered species in a cocktail glass
or some [ __ ] right and I did that
Michelle Obama bit I love that bit yeah
I did it out in Malibu [ __ ] love that
but yeah and dude that day oh my god
dude
I mean I'm surprising and throw me into
the ocean when I and but the [ __ ] but
the guy that I did it's not [ __ ] up my
hitman comes no I'm saying already
[ __ ] it's a private gig dude I didn't
turn into Tony Soprano like that I just
said [ __ ] you what are they gonna what
he gonna do
it's a good joke somebody doesn't like
it but it's a private gig if I was a
comedy you know offend I'm a comedy club
if I'm in a comedy club it's [ __ ] them
if I go to a private gig at some point
read the room stupid like doing a
private gig is an art I don't know how
to do cuz I just go up and I do my [ __ ]
and all I hear is the sound of
silverware don't they know what they're
getting when they book you like it's
like hey hey pay bill dude just so you
know this is a little just what you know
I got to tell you something dude there
there is a level of wealth out there
yeah that you don't even know who they
are they don't know who uses Santa
Monica you say Santa Barbara no it was
in Malibu
but the long story in
well long story short was the guy I was
working for was a billionaire he was a
self-made man and he was a coolest guy
ever and I say hey man sorry about cuz
you know it was kind of an up-and-down
set and he goes nah he goes I love that
I think you say a lot and he was like
that's good he said a lot of [ __ ] up
there people need to hear
that's correct just like this guy's
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and he was see you
know what 7 a drink whatever they ain't
I don't drink anymore you guys know
that's cool he just sat there shooting
the [ __ ] with me yeah and uh and just
like I felt like I was in like a bar
with the guy and we were in this amazing
[ __ ] place in like Malibu or whatever
yeah not everybody who has a shitload of
money
stepped on someone's throat to get here
you know not everybody's a hedge fund
kid like sometimes beer just worked hard
and kind of had a good idea yeah it's
one of those thing it's the same way
like not everybody who's [ __ ] like
broke yeah is is is like I don't know
what are whatever the stereotype is of
that that you're [ __ ] this that and
the other it's just if the whole thing
is [ __ ] stupid but but if you have
money if you're rich it's okay it's it's
considered punching it's the same
ignorant but it's considered punching up
for whatever reason don't yet don't you
notice that everybody is on one side so
[ __ ] like everybody's like like like
this coronavirus thing which I woke up
today and I which by the way is curable
I yeah I figured it out this morning I
go I go yes it's curable I love when you
say figured it out no no but this I like
my favorite thing is when you preface it
with I thought about it I figured it out
no listen though I won't I figured out
Bill you know I thought about it I
figured it out I just realized something
I remember Matt Damon and you just did
the math problem and you continued
pushing your broom I woke up today and I
go you know what I go it's funny how
this [ __ ] happens during an election and
I'm not saying it's a political thing
but they're really the media keeps
talking about this so I looked up today
you know how many people are on the
United States 328 mill over 328 million
people living United States of America
you know how many cases are in the
United States right now 76 cases of
coronavirus only people died one and she
was 89 years old so they're basically
like this is like a really bad flu that
is airborne and if you get it you need
to be if you're healthy and you get it
you could be
you for but I'm looking the media is
actually making people like panicked
about it for he was funny this guy at
the farmers market he had this [ __ ]
mask on like I swear to God I went to
the movie three all [ __ ] where
everybody had him on I'm going like I'm
going like Adam Sandler movie you know
something on glasses mad god bless them
god bless them for doing it because if
they have it you're not gonna get it I I
don't mind my people being over-prepared
but I just look at it like that [ __ ] is
in China where you can't even [ __ ]
roll over in your bed without running
into 36 people and they've been able to
[ __ ] contain it just a couple
thousand people I think would be alright
I think so too and I'm not saying it's
not something to be concerned about this
microphone cover out no I just yeah I
was like it's this whole media thing
where it's like and you know and then
it's funny cuz like somebody was like
alia the stock market took a dip when
they still media kept talking about it
it's like stop scaring people like I was
literally talking to somebody they go
hey man I just let me like scroll to the
phone I'm just checking his Corona
saying dude hold on a second and they
were like reading it like something was
gonna and I want it to be like dude like
it's it's weird it always happens
remember SARS yeah and then hate a
person back east go like hey man just
checking in on you out there in LA
everybody back here that's all they're
talking about is LA and the coronavirus
sounds like yeah no one's really talking
about it out here dude that's like every
time there's a fire out here though just
check it out make sure all right so
every time there's a fire it's supposed
to be like right behind my house not
saying it can't happen but it's just
like you know there's a riot in a mall
bill you guys good or yeah I don't call
Kansas a the time there's a [ __ ] we
don't know anybody out there every time
there's a [ __ ] tornado hey man take
six hours of drive through the state hey
man just making sure yeah it's like
people are so [ __ ] dumb man you know
even like Kansas have so much land there
could be a tornado on their property and
I don't let's say watch the news I don't
think they know what happened barn there
may be a bit of an exaggeration
they shoot their neighbor the next day
he took half from a [ __ ] cattle fence
there was a [ __ ] tornado on the
northeast corner your property you
weren't paying attention you fell asleep
before the news anyway you know what I
saw I don't know what I wanted to plug
yes do you I'm doing this [ __ ]
show man with dean del rey let's [ __ ]
read
we were talking I'll article talking
about that when we were up in your
helicopter I knew this is right yeah
whoa yeah oh yeah
Albertina cool story and there's a big
part of the story or twist to go whoa or
he sits it I like what he would be like
abs dude the other night I was riding on
my motorcycle 210 and this [ __ ] guy
in an SUV like for a half a second
swerved over I was just looks like whoa
[Applause]
whoa is always like whoa to me is like I
almost fell out of my chair
whoa did Dean is I almost lost my leg on
a motorcycle whoa - Dean is my holy [ __ ]
yeah no I think it's no but attributed
to like something life thread but
anyways you know I used to used to front
of rock rock man and he knows all of
those [ __ ] guys yeah so he does this
show every couple of years he does like
a tribute to ac/dc right you know sing a
whole album like when he turns 50 he
sang the whole highway - he did a whole
[ __ ] comedy show all right and all
these guys come on had nice enough to
have me on there and then in the end he
goes I'm gonna sing the Highway to Hell
album and I think the crowd thought like
all right this is gonna be like a dad
band or whatever and through it he just
had these monsters crushed it yeah he
had Tracy guns from LA guns he had I've
got him [ __ ] I think you have Scott
Ian on that one [ __ ] you from anthrax he
had Rudy Sarzo from Ozzy Osbourne
Whitesnake all they [ __ ] monsters
yeah and all of a sudden this this
[ __ ] band on stage just destroying
and the crowd is just like dude well I
what the [ __ ] right so we're doing this
he's nice enough to ask me to be down on
us so it's been 40 years since bonds got
the first like so technically if you and
ac/dc had the second singer and AC but
the first famous guy in lead singer ney
cdz he died in February 1980 so it's the
40th anniversary so he's doing the whole
live if you want blood you got it album
and do the guys that are coming down on
this [ __ ] thing I don't I don't want
to spoil the surprises but the [ __ ]
names is kind of like who's who
especially if drummers
yeah and I loved and guitar players and
all of this and bass players and [ __ ]
are coming down it's gonna so it's me
and him we're gonna do the show I don't
know who else is doing stand-up we're
gonna do like a legit [ __ ] stand-up
show and then the end you're gonna get
like this a live ac/dc album it's at the
the Avalon right across from Capitol
Records
March 10th here in LA do people like
flying in because they saw clips of the
last one and Dean [ __ ] kills it it's
got a killer voice and anyways there's
like 150 tickets left I think and it's
gonna be next a week from tomorrow
March 10th a Tuesday and it's one of my
favorite things ever so I'm gonna sit in
for a song or two no nice yeah after
like some absolute peace I think Steve
Gorman is coming in again Steve Gorman
of Black Crowes frame and Steve Gorman
sports podcast radio show and I always
loved his drumming in the Black Crowes
dude and I saw him playing live doing
the ac/dc [ __ ] like first of all he came
out there and when he showed up for like
soundcheck yeah Dean was just going he's
like oh man he goes this is gonna be fun
and he just looked at him Tori seriously
he goes you see this out here he and he
was just pointing out to where the empty
seats are he goes that's gonna be
[ __ ] carnage tonight like he came out
like like games said that the drummer
Steve Gorby wow this is gonna be [ __ ]
carnage like he didn't he wasn't [ __ ]
around he's like no we're doing this
justice I love that yeah so that's the
attitude of people on this it's gonna be
[ __ ] that's yeah yeah I'm very
excited I'm very excited that's awesome
slash nervous cuz I'm playing one song
so what always happens is I'm you know
once I get out there I'm cool
but then after once I do my [ __ ]
that I can enjoy the rest of the being
nervous is great being nervous as part
of it man if you're not nervous you're
[ __ ] up I think yeah you know I would
I would say so anyone I got you read
some [ __ ] advertising here I totally
didn't listen what you're saying cuz I'm
so busy they Pia nervous is okay or
something like that I'm just going like
yeah I'm like look there's a bill I
don't like you any more friendships over
yeah yeah cool I left steps you just
alright I got to do the
I got to do my face funny I'm literally
looking at the ad reads I can't even do
that before you start looking at your
phone this is how it is now how it is
nowadays oh hey by the way have you seen
have you seen the the e60 drew bledsoe
yes how great was that dude I didn't
understand how hard he got hit and did
you hear what happened in the ambulance
yeah when his brothers sitting there his
brother goes he just [ __ ] he faded out
we were like what you know if he died
cuz his lungs were had a clot in his
lungs dude they were about the fact that
when he came back and they didn't give
him his job and he didn't lose the job
he got hurt so the job was his and
Belichick goes I'm sticking with Brady
and tremendously embarrassing and he has
to [ __ ] stand there and he could have
been the biggest nightmare ever and we
wouldn't want you could have divided the
team and we would not have [ __ ] won
the Super Bowl that year and gone on
don't you know what in he that yeah he
was just took it like a champ it was
like I'm not gonna be a jerk but at the
end of the season you know we sit there
and he's smiling wave didn't go to the
parade I'm [ __ ] out of here and he
took out our members took out a
full-page ad thanked everybody in Boston
and then went to Buffalo and through the
end to I loved one he's I don't know
spoiler alert here when they were saying
do you think Belichick made a mistake he
goes absolutely if he sucks with me we
would have won eight it's just like I
love hearing him say that that's awesome
yeah do it
none of that he's just like drinking
wine now relax names it's still in shape
II look [ __ ] great was a really
really good quarterback Parcells loved
him everybody who put everybody who
played with him loved him like he was a
good dude but it was crazy to hear they
were like it was the loudest hit they've
like ever heard yeah
once again mole ate it in real time dude
and it just looked like he just went
down like a sow dude it was brutal yeah
no it was bad it was just it's unreal
and that that clip and then Brady comes
out it's just like I don't know Brady
going yeah he's not unfortunately he's
not getting his job back when blood
cells like telling his mom like oh he's
gonna get a job now it's so good I'm
glad he's getting like happy and great
he's going like he's never this is it
he's never come he's never getting his
job back and he did yeah didn't that guy
in the Cowboys do the same thing he said
he's I don't know what that wasn't
Bledsoe it was Tony Romo he's like he's
not getting his job back who's who's I
was a cowboy squirtle quarterback now
it's dak
Prescott isn't even one who said that by
the way you think Tommy teeth don't you
think Tommy terrific's coming back or
not dude if I was him I try to get if
he's good at broadcasting I'd get into
that game because Tony Romo just got a
one of the sickest contrary have a Tony
Romo's like he got that contract cuz
he's just ridiculous he's amazing
yeah like but that's gonna play the same
game on half as good as him yeah [ __ ]
eight and a half but Brad Brady
something's wrong with Brady like Brady
wants to keep playing it's like like
Brady wants to keep proving it and it's
like he can't shut it off he can't shut
it off it's great yeah it's great until
he's no I don't want to see that guy
getting scraped off the [ __ ] field
the way they did Brett Favre you know um
yeah but he's not Brett Favre but he is
a certain age yeah he's 43 man he's 43
yeah he is 43 but it's like I just got a
feeling I don't know but like they
protect quarterbacks more than they used
to he also doesn't throw back over the
middle against his body which was a big
Brett Favre thing gun to my head just
know he would never throw the gun to my
head I loved Brett Farr Brett Farr
everyone get breath quadruple cover he's
like yeah I can get it in there and I
don't know if I want to see this but gun
to my head I wish I think that Brady
goes somewhere else for a year like I
think Brady's gonna do a Montana didn't
you or no you always say what Montana
did Montana didn't do that did him on
time I go to the Kansas City Chiefs no
they [ __ ] forced him out and said
we're going with Steve Young that's why
he left oh okay see you know not oh okay
I've told you that like 40 [ __ ] times
did you yeah and then all those times
when he was going like Brady's yeah but
no but my head [ __ ] Montana when it
took him four times to get [ __ ] a
size 14 for soup no no no you would say
this one he had like [ __ ] no I said
it when he had three no first of all
when he had [ __ ] three he was still
saying Peyton Manning was better I said
Peyton Manning was the best
regular-season quarter I said oh you
didn't
I had to pick somebody was 200 506 when
I first got to know that's when I first
got you you told me that and everybody
in the SP ni if you got a pic I gotta
[ __ ] get it
the guy had three [ __ ] rings and
couldn't get arrested I did say that I
did I did in O seven I said Payton was
better then I flipped it and I did say
when Brady had three this is how hard
you flip dope all
you went from Payton is better to Tom
Brady and in an 11 month period you went
to Tom Brady is the greatest quarterback
of all time which in the end you ended
up being right on but like this is why I
did flip quick but yeah I felt like I
did I did get it right well Paul this is
the thing if you [ __ ] shoot a zillion
half-court shots one's gonna go in but
not wood unless somebody but you're not
deadly from that range these guys dude
you have a mountain of chips in every
hand you push them all in and one of
those times you're gonna be like dude I
want 10 million in that hand but Joe
Montana didn't have to go to Kansas City
Joe Montana could have left what I'm
saying Joe Montana could stop playing at
that time right could have finished a
San Francisco 49er for his career this
is a different argument no what I'm
saying is I hear what you're saying but
what I'm saying is Joe Montag hope
you're here I'm gonna go put another
jersey on I'm gonna go to another team
after my legacy in San Francisco and he
actually ended up heat but he was forced
out the Patriots are not forcing Tom
Brady out they're letting him see what
is out there and then they're just gonna
match it and then just see you know what
he does yeah because he's been a good
guy think we've always had him locked
down he's taken less money and
everything let the guy do this it is a
thing to if he does leave you know III
know patriot fan should have a [ __ ]
problem with it no but it's a tough
thing to see as a patriot fan it would
be a tough thing to see like if Eli went
to the Jaguars or did something like
that I'm not comparing you I managed to
Tom Brady by any stretch but seeing that
guy beat him twice
see I think he's in the comes a sheeter
seeing Jeter in a you know it's like
we've talked about this before there's
been some bad ones and you know seeing
Jeter and another uniform it's like you
can't that's why I love ya but then you
know something then years later Mitchell
and
nests makes the [ __ ] Joe nameth Los
Angeles Rams [ __ ] Jersey and it's the
[ __ ] of the Johnny Unitas righteous
Jersey and then it's a mean it's it's
hard to see I guess as a sports fan I
don't know well you know I think it's
harder like in some sports but not in
like basketball
let's talk basketball Paul and what they
can do to fix the [ __ ] NBA and get
out of this era of the [ __ ] super
teams because if I see one more team
loaded with free agents and listen to
them afterwards you know we just need
one more piece it's like how many good
guys from other teams do you [ __ ]
need before you guys can [ __ ] get on
the same goddamn page yeah and win
something like I it's it's always like
they hit like three monster teams yeah
it's like every jock in your grade all
piles on one team and then they play the
math team every other [ __ ] night and
win by 40 [ __ ] points do that thing
let me let me let me do the let me do
the [ __ ] reads here oh look who's
here but I bop bop me undies me undies
you got a piling [ __ ] team they do
dick me undies me undies it's a
nightmare it's not a dream watching you
win by 45 over a team he used to [ __ ]
play sorry come on man KD going from
[ __ ] Oklahoma to the Warriors I mean
what the [ __ ] is that like they had a
3-1 [ __ ] lead they didn't know how to
win and then the bitterness would set it
and then the next year you would get to
see the war can they finally put the
demons to bed now he'd be like if Jordan
just joined the [ __ ] Pistons yeah and
Jordan stuck with it and that a magic
joins the Celtics after they look the
Lakers lose to [ __ ] in matey for a
bird joins the Lakers gay after they
lose to the Lakers in 85 they'd be the
dumbest thing ever you want to know how
go ahead do your I mean you keep luring
me in here though not gonna lie I know
you're sitting you're going me undies it
and you're like it'd be like if Durant
and I'm like waiting to jump imagine
your fifth-grade self looking into the
future and learning that as an adult you
got me undies
membership they would laugh hysterically
butt jokes on them because me undies is
known for their supersoft undies and
they're flexible fun membership if you
choose to sign up you'll get parts perks
like site wide savings free shipping and
new undies delivered to your door each
month
fourth be an adult and sign up for that
me undies membership even if your past
self is laughing at you you've probably
heard me undies are the softest undies
to ever grace your nethers that's
because they're made of micro modal
modal what the heck is that the magical
sustainable softest heck fabric made
from trees yes trees that makes your
bits feel like they're floating on a
cloud they're designed to be the softest
thing you ever put on your body and
offer it in a range of sizes from extra
small to four XL oh that pickup truck
shaken again Paul different prints
colors and styles me undies doesn't like
to just make undies they also have
loungewear which has recently had a glow
up whatever that means check out their
new line of style micro modal Motel
lounge where you can wear in and out of
the house they know they're on every
part they know they're on every podcast
but that's just because they're looking
for the true undie domination they won't
stop until you all try them me undies
has a great offer for my listeners for
any first-time purchasers you get 15%
off free shipping there is this is a
no-brainer especially because they have
100% satisfaction guarantee to get you
15% off your first pair free shipping a
hundred percent satisfaction guaranteed
go to me on DS comm / / that's me undies
comm / Barnard sorry Paul I suck at
reading out loud to more policy genius
you know if there's one things humans
aren't great at its predicting the
future
Paul virzi would disagree yes I would I
would like that I could do it just take
a look I don't even if you weren't
joking I I know your track record just
take a look you love a head case just
take a look around know the amount of
guys that you said this guy's gonna
[ __ ] bluff about that ended up blowing
up a [ __ ] locker room we got a call
with there's got to be a name for that
just take a look around no amount of
crystal balls fortune cookies or tea
leaves could predict the world we're
living in right now but unpredictability
is also what keeps life interesting the
trick is to enjoy the ride without
worrying and what's about what's around
the corner and one way to worry less is
to protect the things you've worked so
hard for like your home which means you
need and home insurance which means you
should probably
try policy genius first head to policy
genius comm and answer a few questions
about yourself and your property then
policy genius will compare your policy
against other options from top insurers
to make sure you're getting the right
home insurance coverage at the best
possible price they save their customers
an average of six hundred ninety dollars
per year doing just that if policy
genius finds you a better rate than what
you're currently paying they'll do the
work to get you switched own a car -
policy genes will compare your home and
auto policies against different insurers
and even mix and match to find your
savings you get it whatever you're
trying to ensure these guys can figure
out where to go for the best for the
least so if you haven't found out if you
haven't found a play-by-play breakdown
breakdown of your future inside a
crystal ball or a cookie that's okay
protect the things you've worked hard
for and get home insurance with policy
genius in just a few minutes you can
find your best price and apply a policy
genius com policy genius we will always
get the future wrong better get home
insurance right heavy well pointed
[ __ ] fortune cookies stop being a
fortune and it just started being advice
yeah it kind of used to be like a you
know you're gonna [ __ ] they're
delicious though now the glaze the sweet
glaze on on a fortune cookies pretty
nice I don't know it's kind of like I
don't know it seems like it's something
that's not edible that they put sugar on
and then you eat it it there is a
fakeness so the fear is it still tastes
good it's like something desert like
someone was trying to make a potty talk
food yeah we can if I can read LegalZoom
real quick alright LegalZoom it's still
early in the year
can we talk food buddy talk sneakers
we're in sports don't sneak away when
we're running out of topics it's a
couple of dopes but we're doing well in
life should give all of you guys hope
it's still early in the year but if you
run a small business you know 2020 will
fly by that's why you should use
LegalZoom right now to make sure you're
set up for success over the past 19
years LegalZoom has helped more than 2
million Americans start their businesses
by incorporating forming in Ellis LLC
and more but even after your
this is your business is setup LegalZoom
could still help you out with a lot more
things like lease agreements changing
tax laws and reviewing contracts all
play a part in running your own business
these are precisely the kinds of costly
hurdles that can take time away from
your growing business don't let that
happen
legal zooms network of independent
attorneys and tax professionals can
provide advice to address these things
and more and you'll never get charged by
the hour since Legal Zoom isn't a law
firm go to legalzoom.com today and enter
the promo code burn in the box at the
checkout for special savings that's
legalzoom.com code birbee you are our
Legal Zoom where life meets legal Paul
this print is so [ __ ] small I got to
I got to tell you something I I refuse
to get glasses and I'm telling you yo
you read that like in the back of the
class and you just had to read a
paragraph out loud while being nervous
to look how small this princess look at
that print that is that is you're gonna
do the bartnik squint yeah no but I'm a
big believer in not getting glasses
because they just [ __ ] ruin your eyes
and then you need them I agree with that
because they gave me prescription just
for driving and then it made when I took
them off it like I just think I'm not
doing this yeah you have like a [ __ ]
hit I had I had this adjusting thing I'm
like why would I just do my thing you
feel like it's a scam I kind of feel
like LASIK eye surgery like they know
how to do it better than they're doing
it but they're like if we just fix it
then they're not gonna come back and you
know have to [ __ ] do it again isn't
there something about that I'm just
waiting for them to perfect that I think
what's [ __ ] [ __ ] Paul as a fellow
guy who's [ __ ] bald here the fact
that they can put a laser on your eye
and all of a sudden you can see all the
way to Kentucky yeah but they can't
figure out to get high to make your hair
stop falling under your [ __ ] head
there's guys should yeah if it's your
polio how we're just slowed down [ __ ]
AIDS
so [ __ ] weird would it be though if
we took a pill we just pumped out all
the way I'll be the greatest thing ever
like what hairstyle
dude I would have I would have Andy Gibb
hair you take a pill Monday and by
Saturday you just got a [ __ ] mop the
excitement of coming back would be just
it would be ridiculous I mean I actually
beyond with beyond zoo I love having a
[ __ ] once you shave your head going bald
sucks once you shave your head you
[ __ ] cool I mean I said you're cool
but you're flying in a barber chair
where the guy actually had the brush and
like you felt the comb and he cut it and
you looked at a picture of a style and
you just talk to him I missed that I
actually missed the barbershop
camaraderie man a cool barber bad eye
that was that that I bet I do miss yeah
I do but you can go down and just hang
out all right listen I got one for you
gun to your head one's got to go one's
got to go the rest of your life okay
sushi or pizza you could never have that
another one again oh this no this is
no-brainer dude
what Paul there's like no fish left stop
eating fish I meant taste wise forget
take that away I'm a sushi lesser plus a
pizza like 15 days of the month I could
not eat sushi that much and I gave you a
CD Paul there's there's very few good
sushi restaurants there's a lot of
people out there doing the sushi thing
just like pizza yeah all right but
here's the thing
did I just had to eat at an airport yeah
bad pizza I can handle I can get through
a bad pizza bad sushi is [ __ ] sketchy
there's people out there they'll make
fish tastes like butter it'll like melt
in your mouth and then there's the rest
of them there's the rest of them when we
were at Nobu for my birthday it blew my
mind but I just had like a spicy tuna
roll at JFK and it was like you know
well Paul who the [ __ ] gets sushi at an
airport it was like a nice restaurant
all like was it I mean now but it wasn't
awful you know what I mean I see that
there you go
well I'll go with that that's what
you're getting in an airport it wasn't
awful Europe that gets a little crazier
at the airports
Southeast Asia thing I've got to tell
you something Southeast Asia Singapore I
was [ __ ] there they had these
dumplings dude that it was just like how
the [ __ ] is this at an airport and I'll
tell this story forever this [ __ ]
dumpling eating [ __ ] he went
back like 19 times he ate most of them
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] [ __ ] I got this
[ __ ] guy you know and it was so
[ __ ] funny when you're in Southeast
Asia right dude it's like you're on
another [ __ ] planet
yeah it's their own Airlines their own
pop stars the hope that's so [ __ ] far
away completely different race of people
there's barely any [ __ ] white people
you see and you're like wow man this is
what they feel like when they're [ __ ]
over here it's just like you get this
great experience and you go over there
right and it's just but then what
happens is after you're over there a
couple of days you just start seeing
people you know like I said if something
like if that [ __ ] [ __ ] lounge that's
it's like I get it you're in the lounge
you trying to get your money's worth but
you're being [ __ ] rude and I'm not
gonna say who the guy is the guy is
right and I was just like oh my god this
is [ __ ] Southeast Asia's [ __ ]
Eddie [ __ ] whatever that I know
[ __ ] back from Massachusetts yeah
yeah I know I don't like that [ __ ] I
don't like it either
yeah I don't like that I don't like that
[ __ ] nothing nothing worse
nothing was these dumplings Paul yeah
but they're not though we are they know
Paul T they can't be no they were yeah
the ones over here at doughy though yeah
they're too doughy they did not to make
them it's solid East agent said get the
[ __ ] out of here and serve that to
Americans
dude you're shouting right now I love
how you I love how you're pointing and
taking it that seriously call these
[ __ ] dumb you're a kid that takes
food really seriously through these
dumplings Paul these things think it was
almost like they were hovering above the
[ __ ] plate they were so light and I
was like of course they are this is
where they came from
it's like going to Italy and being like
oh this is what a tomato is supposed to
taste like this is how Italian this is
Italian food yeah you go to [ __ ]
Southeast now yeah those [ __ ] people
throw everywhere around the world they
throw down but like it was so great
after all these years of thinking I was
having authentic this authentic deck to
[ __ ] be there and even in an airport
the [ __ ] dumplings at the airport
were better than any [ __ ] [ __ ]
I've had over here Nobu and all those
[ __ ] all of those they go over there I
will [ __ ] mask yeah I'm not go over
there yeah I got a deal with that at the
airport going back home seeing that well
I wanted to go up to the person I wanted
to like go to up to the person in the
mask I would never do it and be like are
you really what that worried
Paul this you know arrogant you have to
be no there's nothing well there's
nothing wrong with being worried no but
it's almost arrogant to put a mask on
it's almost a little arrogant that if
there's 328 million Americans and 76
got'em and you think that you're that
[ __ ] important that it's gonna catch
you wherever you go
is there a
narcissism there isn't a little [ __ ]
arrogant uh I don't know arrogance the
word I would say maybe your Leonov
involved hypochondriac yeah and then I
saw somebody with like I don't mass
you're not good at an airport so I said
what you're not good in airports though
I'm getting better now I'm getting
member in a like I'm getting better you
know I do that now they have like a jack
you you [ __ ] you like you only a few
guys that I know that you have to see
the pilot and feel okay about what the
guy looks like yes I do
that's yeah I like to look at the pilot
I like to look look at the guy who's
doing it I like to look at the guy who's
doing it and I gave and say half this
[ __ ] that you [ __ ] said what you
could say no I can't all right all right
yeah I guess yeah all right yeah all
right yeah this to put it basically Paul
once a [ __ ] James Bond yes vibe I do
that's what you want I do I do okay I
don't want to [ __ ] doughy dude I saw
some B's don't want that no you don't
want to reboot a James Bond what James
Bond is a woman dude I saw a pilot for
American Airlines just like crushing I
used to do a joke on he could crush in a
Big Mac with like fries at McDonald's
his gut was just protruding over his
thing and he was just like walking to
the plane and I'm just going like this
guy I know what this guy just put in his
body and I always got 200 souls that
he's taken across the country I know you
know what's [ __ ] nuts about that is
how hard it is with the turnarounds and
all that for those guys to try that with
a foot [ __ ] is he going to the gym no no
dude this guy was no this guy was just
Russian fast food you know yeah I told
you I was on line one time and this
pilot this guy was going to Hawaii or
something it was funny he was like a
heavyset black dude and he goes I go
look I ask you something just went early
when I was nervous flying I ask you
something man is like I was like like is
it okay like weather does weather matter
he goes all today is actually a good day
cuz you know it's a little hazy plane
small planes won't go up so it's you
know it's less you know I never
like that he was wondering how I learned
man he goes I learned on a video game
man and like said it like that so I
learned on a video game man
he's like this is all computers man
sings [ __ ] and I was just like Oh what
and he was like gap I just learned on it
and I was like yeah the autopilot it's
like it's it's like he said it's a
computer to flies a plane and then until
it comes to a now it's gonna take off
and then probably take off and then they
tell you to turn whatever heading and
then you just put it on the autopilot I
mean I don't obviously I don't know how
it works but I mean you can literally
just set the altitude that you want to
go to and then you know you have there's
another button that just automatically
pressurizes the cabin and all that which
during your pre-flight you got to make
sure that that [ __ ] thing is on or
all of a sudden you're gonna start
talking to your co-pilot nothing's gonna
make sense they can make weird radio
calls then you're gonna pass out and
eventually run out of gas I tell you
Mark Teixeira was on my airplane that
was Mark Teixeira was on my airplane
uh-huh and I had an abort abort landing
where we almost touched I'm not even
joking we were probably I'm not even
kidding we were everyone's getting their
[ __ ] together and we'd probably like we
were right there I thought work I
thought the wheels were gonna touch and
all of a sudden he just went and went
right back up and nobody said [ __ ] and
everybody was going like this I was like
this guy just saw my car dude like I
just like I wasn't we were there and
people were going one guy's going like
this and I told you the windshear so the
guy came on he told us he goes listen is
there was some dangerous stuff because
we got a route like a rough wind shears
like we're gonna come or I'll be down
and then when he finally hit the second
time everybody just like went forward
and somebody's people's heads were
hitting and he just had to do it and
it's like you were saying I think you
said another three like donek I probably
saved our lives
yeah cuz people end up I don't people
[ __ ] about a hard landing like the guy
sucks or the woman sucks who's flying
the plane a lot of people will talk
about wind shear and they don't even
know what it is
it just means you you're you're going
you you always take off and land into
the wind okay and what happens shears as
it goes from like a headwind to it to a
tailwind so now the way the wing is
designed the way the wind is flowing
over it you know you're not gonna get
that low pressure high pressure going to
low pressure lifts unless you fly faster
so then when you start to fly faster
your landing faster than you normally do
means you could possibly run out of
runway okay you know there's all kinds
of [ __ ] arrow didn't and then as far
as I may not obviously don't fly
fixed-wing so I don't understand a lot
of that [ __ ] yeah but I know with like
helicopters with us that there's wind
shear you know it won't you it will spin
us around like a [ __ ] weather vane
you just oh you could have like loss of
tail rotor effect all of that type of
[ __ ] but like where's aviation in a go
man
like 15 25 years something like that's
gonna get even say it's getting it's
gonna it's gonna be safer and probably
faster you know whatever happened at
Concorde I'm that Concorde plane that
plane went from like New York to London
in two and a half hours such a trash and
then there was like what a fluke [ __ ]
thing happened that the [ __ ] tire
came off I was taken off and somehow
went up a building is right yeah went up
into the engine he lost an engine it
caught on fire and then the only [ __ ]
smashed into a [ __ ] hotel yeah and
then what happens is like I don't see
that one's a fucked-up one because that
was actually not human error like pilot
error is the thing that like you know
that's a mechanical failure yeah that's
a scary one because for me at McKinnon
pilot error is not nearly as scary to me
as like saying like you know the COBE
thing happens every there's like jello I
was a [ __ ] dangerous
it'd be like if the guy was just flying
in the main road or [ __ ] just came
off right and then a few days later on a
completely different model the same
thing happened then it's time what do
you like what the [ __ ] I'm not flying
yeah yeah of course but if somebody is
always like that guy shouldn't have been
up there and he made a bad decision rest
his soul as somebody like [ __ ] yeah
little Cessna decides to fly in just
like I saw when this guy flew and
whatever he had he was looking at an old
whatever his I don't know I don't fly in
weather like that but whatever he was
looking at was it was not an updated map
of the weather's the system that was
going on so he had something from an
hour ago
yeah and so he was flying by that and
the guys on the go and you're flying
right into this [ __ ] thing and he
just in one of those little ass [ __ ]
Cessnas and there was he flew into some
[ __ ] that would throw a dc-10 or a
[ __ ] 747 around and that was just it
ripped his [ __ ] wing off let's not
talk about this Paul yeah let's talk
about let's talk about the Houston
Astros and how is [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] about that stuff I'm so glad they
did that [ __ ] damn [ __ ] every [ __ ]
anybody you know it's just like I [ __ ]
them no [ __ ] everybody now the Yankees
deserved that they deserved it you know
who didn't deserve it though man that
[ __ ] kid who came forward on the
Dodgers and goes yeah I guess they're
right what they start show hey guys I
guess the right to say I choked in the
playoffs and then they went back to the
tape and they said every every breaking
ball in the playoffs when the Astros
were home against them he they hit every
every batter against Kershaw when he
threw that breaking ball to one of the
greatest Braddock hit got it got contact
and they said it's never happened before
and then they showed the numbers when
they were playing the Dodgers Dodgers
[ __ ] the Dodgers they spent they spent a
ton of [ __ ] money the Yankees and Red
Sox due to how many [ __ ] World Series
did we win the Yankees and Red Sox
combined with a hundred eighty to two
hundred million dollar teams with
roided-up free engines I mean it would
like that wasn't cheating on some that
was an unfair [ __ ] advantage and as
far as like also knowing what pitch is
coming you know I just look at it like
that you know the Astros never won one
they finally brought they finally
brought a gun to a gunfight people are
cheating every [ __ ] game and this
enough and there's nothing to and the
NBA is fixed
here's another funniest thing you want
to talk about cheating I would say fix
its finessed in that day everything that
they can to have the two months two
teams be there and absolutely
nope not calling the big guy yes that
manipulative that minute and and no
absolutely Kevin Garnett sitting on Bill
Simmons when the Celtics get that game
seven crazy throws at that we were not
part of the NBA's agenda it's the
closest thing you'll ever hear a player
go like this [ __ ] was fixed yeah
absolutely
no come on Jordan got calls I think I
think there is LeBron is gonna get calls
too you know in a big moment they want
they want do they want Laker Celtics
they want they want
that or but the thing but what they did
though was they rebranded Lakers Celtics
with they learned that it worked when
the heat was a monster team they learned
that when the Golden State Warriors were
monster team yeah where it was just like
people peaked in just because they
wanted to see the the you know David
versus Goliath well doing that when they
after that Donaghey thing when they said
like they had meetings going infra she'd
Wallace and Allen Iverson opened their
mouth once TM up even if it's not worthy
of if another player did it was just
like they had these like rules and then
do when you watch that Kings Lakers and
but that's the kind of thing though with
that individual [ __ ] though that's like
one of those things where like it's kind
of an earned reputation by the piano
then had I get up I said baseball you're
gonna be like a [ __ ] and show up the UMP
you're not gonna get that call in the
corner you just not yeah if they don't
like you but that Kings series when
they're just looking confused and you're
like this game is completely [ __ ]
manipulated right you know you just
gotta be yeah you just got a bit like
now these got you got to be like
undeniably good just like comedy you
told me that by the way like you know
it's funny and I wanted to I wanted to
get your take on this - cuz but I don't
know remember I call you remember I
remember calling you up like years ago
and being like and being like yeah do
Montreal said no and then the next year
I was like yeah dude I had a good and
they said no and you go Paul you go you
have to get undeniable a guy like you
has to get undeniable to get internet
festival and then the next year I got in
and I because I just had undeniable
things and I feel like everybody in
comedy I don't know how many comedians
listen to this and [ __ ] but this is
something I wanted to say I'm sure they
do but like I hear everybody going like
you got to get on that podcast and you
got to go and do this it has changed and
you got to go and do that and like get
on this pot and it's just like nobody
seems like it just feels like I think
just getting good at what you do will
eventually get into ways that I see that
roads that people take there is the I'm
gonna be in the mix guy and whatever's
the hot thing I got I got a B and I
don't get yeah I don't agree with that I
think I agree with that that's people do
that but I don't agree with that Avenue
that works for some people right what
worked for me was to let go of all I
mean I still went for it and [ __ ] but I
just was not the guy they were gonna
pick so the [ __ ] that I was doing the
way that I looked was like the business
was not looking for it like you know
they're looking for a good look at
people and then and then now they're
looking for people that will make them
not look sexist and racist and
homophobic the exact same white people
that were not giving those people
opportunities they're now going out of
their [ __ ] way and what I love about
it is they're still not doing the work
the same way like when they were picking
white guys they would always pick the
wrong [ __ ] white guy would you get
the legit dude they just poke their head
and alright let's just take this guy
he's got a nice square [ __ ] head they
doing the same thing so which is what
gives all things comedy not that thought
the [ __ ] pep my cone company you know
partial company on its back but like we
live like that yeah I mean I got I got a
totally [ __ ] oh yeah we try to [ __ ] me
try to picture spit the [ __ ] if you
just try to pick the best people you're
gonna accidentally be progressive but
yes but look I you know I was coming up
I was told I mean dude there were times
I was down and and I think you going
through the path that you went through
and then me having a guy like you go
like dude you just got it you're just
they're not just gonna pick you and I'm
like yeah and then am i okay and you got
to go harder it's better but like know
do what you love I love doing stand-up
for getting better at stand-up every
time right every time I just like
getting better I didn't get any people
all dude podcast it's like I didn't
getting this person to be a [ __ ]
radio host right look I need like some
guy I didn't I think I got in the
business to like I'll jump I have my
podcast of erzsi effect and it's fun but
I did it just to shoot the [ __ ] have my
fans listen to it if they want to me and
you can shoot the [ __ ] I go on my
friends but listening to people going
you got to get out you got to get on
this podcast you get on that get on that
podcast and I'm like what do you love I
love stand up I love do you know what I
love I love doing a bit and having one
of my peers go dude that's a [ __ ]
killer bit dude that's a top one of your
top jokes and then [ __ ] working on
that and I feel like if you do that
Chris Rock said something dope where he
just goes and goes I got he goes I got
great when I stopped trying to be famous
dude I just [ __ ] did like I just
stopped trying to be famous because like
all I wanted to do was try to get
something famous well I bet is that's
where you also
tap into your own power it's like when
you're chasing it then it's just like
you're gonna start oh they like blue
shirts I'm gonna wear blue shirts oh
yeah the only they'd late though like
this is they hey this is the hairstyle
this is the [ __ ] topics yeah and I
saw like all of the you know I saw you
know I saw these [ __ ] guys run into
those alt rooms yeah after the club
comics who started those rooms kind of
moved on to the next level of their
careers right there was all these people
that just ran to those [ __ ] rooms
because they were hot and then those
same [ __ ] people when those rooms got
cold ran away and ran back to this was
such a it's it's that's so [ __ ] hard
it's such a hard way I think to try and
get there than to just be like you know
what I'm gonna get what I'm supposed to
get and I'm just gonna say what the [ __ ]
I want to say and if this doesn't get me
all the way to whether I wanted to be I
I won't like have regrets cuz because
there's nothing worse than going down
swinging with somebody else's idea what
you should have said right like if I go
down if I go down it's gonna be going
down with my plan my Avenue under my
[ __ ] terms and for me right now like
that's been awesome and it's been which
for young comics listening that does not
mean self-sabotage no because there's a
bunch of people that I came up with and
I still see to this day where they're
just sabotaging themselves and then they
do this [ __ ] business so they can't
have you seen what's on the internet
anybody like me is really [ __ ] funny
it's taking yourself so ridiculously
serious what the self sabotage is always
going to be there what about these
comics that are [ __ ] brilliant and
and and I've seen it a million times and
obviously I'm not gonna mention names
but I've seen comics that are [ __ ]
brilliant and just [ __ ] drink
themselves out of the business they just
drink themselves they're either at the
party getting hammered slurring words
and then you know they're not getting up
to writing because they're all hungover
and I'm like dude that was meat like
when I first came up I'd hit the scene
doing shots and everything I'm like oh
this this has to slow down you know like
this is like
you know you gotta [ __ ] I think it's
a certain type of person though I think
that like rest his soul I think that the
kobe bryant's I think that the Tom
Brady's I think the Derek Jeter's I
think the Michael Jordan's I think there
are certain people ok and you know in
comedy and I'm not trying to make you
feel uncomfortable but I think you're
one of those people I think I'm one of
those people that I don't accept
I always constants constantly wanna you
know like well I'll be forever chose
chasing the perfect [ __ ] joke yeah but
you're one of those people you're just
you're like a relentless lunatic it with
what you do right you're a relentless
you're a relentless [ __ ] animal and I
feel like I feel like like guys like
that just want to keep you know dude
look at Tom Brady grab his [ __ ]
lineman's facemask and [ __ ] crack I
think I've got six rings and he's like
let's go looking at the crowd let's go
that's not a normal that's why he is who
he is when Kobe Bryant was tearing
congratulating the Celtics and he was
[ __ ] holding it in and like literally
weeping and I'm going dude that guy's
coming back next year or like something
do you know what I mean like I just saw
it you don't see that and there's a lot
of athletes that don't have that dude
yeah I mean I don't know I think what
they do is a lot harder than [ __ ]
telling jokes though I mean I don't have
to [ __ ] know but I think but I don't
think it matters when it comes to work
ethic though you think it matters what
other big names around here pull no but
I think it matters when it comes to work
ethic Turner and I mean like getting on
the plane and doing the radio show in
the morning when it's already sold out
that that's something that I will say
that I don't understand I never
understood the New York Comic the guy
that just stadium in New York how to
know I mean the guy that was just did
the New York club's waiting for that
agent or the manager to come in to sign
them and then they would say what
happened you know and then they I'm just
staying here until I get on TV and then
I'm gonna do the [ __ ] road and it's
like I never understood that I always
always just like no you do the road now
you build up your following and then the
following gets you the TV show or you
got half your following and then the TV
show puts you over the [ __ ] top yeah
because you're half of following tunes
into your show and gets you ratings
I just our I just never understood that
like there was all of these guys when I
came to the city that would [ __ ]
destroy in the city mm-hmm but could
only do like 30 minutes I would go on
the road again yeah they'd get on the
road they would data jokes about
Alphabet City
and riding the [ __ ] e train and
[ __ ] nobody cried too and they were
just like what the [ __ ] is this guy
I had owners in the middle of the
country going you New York guys man he
one time he said he goes ah dude you had
time and I go what do you mean he goes
you did your time the whole way and I
he's like he's like you knew you know
New York guys you guys got that set that
12 to 15 minutes and like they were
sayings like that's why we don't book
too many New Yorkers and that's when I
realized you need to do them both like I
feel like there's an arrogance with you
guys what do you mean you guys think
every other city sucks you think bill I
[ __ ] it [ __ ] place shuts down if I
could turn I could [ __ ] drink till
5:00 in the morning but you guys can't
get a slice down here right yeah yeah
it's the dumbest [ __ ] ever yeah you go
to like San Antonio and you're pissed
cuz you can't get a good slice rather
than going out there like Paul they're
into barbecue this is what the [ __ ] they
do hello we did have a good time in San
Antonio but yeah I just think that
there's there's like a that was one
thing that I didn't understand and I and
I thought and I as a young comic - I
knew I was like thinking going that
doesn't make sense they might be right
because I did see a few people do it but
I was just like or you could [ __ ]
become a monster yeah out here by doing
hours but I think you only do 45 minutes
than I do if they do an hour too close
but doing 45 minutes then you come back
to the city and it's like what I got to
do what you know spots 12 minutes 15
minutes I can do this my sleep yeah one
thing I have to actually credit is my
wife because my wife was just like I
believe in you and like go ahead and I'm
I told her I was AG look I'll try to
contribute what I can right and but
let's just say I wasn't with Stacey and
I didn't have kids and I was in the city
I would have probably got in a car and
had a one-bedroom apartment or something
and try to do the road and all that but
I think that I could have ended up
either being distracted I mean I
probably stolen lost some years in New
York every comic does yeah yeah yeah you
have those my wife dude my wife [ __ ]
held it down
my wife held it down and supported me
dude my
is the best speak of it
speak of the wise hold on the lovely Mia
[Laughter]
hey I'm just I'm just giving my wife
credit on the pot oh there oh they're
tuning out they're like what is this
woman praise right now what if this
woman prays good to tell you crushed it
the other day she crushed it on on the
podcast she goes
we were watching real sports with Bryant
Gumbel we love that [ __ ] yeah we love
that show [ __ ] sitting there watching
at one point we're just watching you
know you know after the guy does the
through the story he comes in and he's
talking to [ __ ] Bryant Gumbel and she
just looks to me she goes what is he
writing down always with a pencil and a
legal pad yeah
put the mic so stick in here I'm just
like what are you what are you writing
down the story is done it's over it's
wrapped up you know it's like on the
fade out exactly I feel like I feel like
he does that because it's a power move
like you're coming you're answering to
me and it's just like a few more
questions that I'm gonna talk to you
after this research why didn't you
viewed people months we've been working
on this the piece is over yeah but he's
still got some I love what Stacey here's
this one I'm going like you know my wife
really like supported me coming up at
comedy and then you just hear Nia coming
I said of course she did that is like
that was like I sorta you would have
thought there was a director going all
right Nia come down now come down right
now that lrq that was perfect
that's great all right it's going good
well you know unfortunately it's it's
the end here
no it's an hour
14 minutes in another hour with Nia I
know I know
how was your night you had a good night
sure oh good to see you alright that was
hilarious
I got to show you when we're done here I
got to show you I went to big 5 sporting
goods and I got a tee ball set for my
daughter cuz she saw the song take me
out to the ball game and she loved the
song and now she wants to go to a
baseball game and she was imitating
swinging a bat
oh yeah and she was doing it Lefty so my
got my god she's gonna make the big
leagues you know second any left-handed
up but that dad just thinks oh my god
she's gonna make the Olympics right I
wish that I could be there cuz you're on
the west coast I'm on the East Coast
dude and I wish I can be there when you
watch her compete in a sporting events
like when I watch Lucas like my son is
getting really good in basketball and
like everybody's like he's got the shot
in the school but like when my son
shoots a three and you're just sitting
there and like you hear other parents go
this one can shoot and like he makes it
or something you're just like there's a
feeling I just want to see your face
when it hits the game-winner oh and the
gym goes goes nuts
I'm gonna be one of two things I'm
either gonna be like standing up going
that's right that's [ __ ] that's a virzi
right there he's got my shot or I'm just
gonna have my hands over my face the
cuts I got to show you the video the cut
she was taken first of all she holds the
bat upside down I'm going like I'm like
sweetheart you want to hold him in she
goes no dad I don't I want a hole like
this alright I don't be the overbearing
person but I'm like alright and she's
just killing the ball and I'm going to
I'll go you know the day you turn that
bat around
she already has like a level swing yeah
and we had like it was great to was she
said I want to do myself so she was like
setting the ball on the tee doing the
whole thing I was like oh my god she's
out here she's doing this activity I can
enjoy it and I can also lay down this is
awesome oh yeah I had the wheel I had
like the best dad day ever today we went
to a farmers market
other than that weirdo with the [ __ ]
SARS masks that guy we went to Big Five
we got
t-ball thing going took a stroll around
the block we just had the best day just
had the best friggin day and then we
watched a little tube in the end had
some chicken potpie
I read a couple of books that's nice
it's just a better than the end of the
night she's like dad I want you to skew
come sleep in my bed like I can't I
can't fit in there
no come sleep my bag I can't and I go
listen tomorrow we're gonna ride bikes
we're gonna do this we're gonna do we're
gonna do all that stuff right but I have
to go to sleep now bye and you can't cry
she goes ok no cry yes I go no screaming
no screaming no screaming to cry then of
course second usually when I close the
door that second she does she starts
going dad this wooden or those but the
ones when she goes dad where are you
you're like oh god I gotta go I'm right
here buddy
I'm right that she just goes rub my back
toys best is when they cheer right when
you don't work like like Sophie oh yeah
how do you gonna work tonight no yes or
like when I go she'll go why why do you
got it goin and I go you know I got it I
gotta go oh you all right but I'm not
working tomorrow
yes she's told me the other night she
goes dad I don't want you to work
anymore oh when you work it'd make me so
upset
Oh God and then she goes I want I see
she ended it with going I need you you
know it look when she said I need you I
go I was like nyet coached or this he's
just fun I said then I said to me I go I
go did you tell her to say that she goes
no I'm like where'd she get this she's
like I don't know oh my god you go to
work I so upset
that's like that would just make me
wanna yeah so I try to explain to us
like I have to go to work she's like why
psych book so I can keep buying
popsicles I try to get on her level oh
yeah it's gonna be no more popsicles and
she's like no Sofia wants a guinea pig
but she had a hamster that got her out
so now she wants a guinea pig
and she's just like you pluck her bottom
lip was quivering she promised me we
would I said I said we were going look
okay I would say I know everybody's
saying that they're [ __ ] filthy what
the thing is Sophia comes in our bed
every night right they [ __ ] all over the
place yeah and I go you don't have you
sleep in your bed for two weeks straight
and she didn't she didn't you know she
comes but I told I'm uncomfortable
sometimes in there like you know she the
whole thing I'm like eh but that wasn't
the agreement
so then now so now we got all these it's
funny become like an agent
well you like negotiate you know how
does I say that was a good one because
you you gave her you gave her the
illusion of choice sir
well actually no she could have stayed
in there but you knew that was a stacked
in the NBA you got a job in the NBA then
you finesse that one I knew because she
needs she wants that she doesn't like to
stay in there and here's what we do
we hear a little rustle with the
doorknob and then we hear it and then
you hear little foot pattern went down
the hallway and then you just see her
silhouette and hi can I just
and then she just gets in and I'm just
saying that you hi Daddy
I'm like anyone might you know take know
the other night my daughter had a
nightmare so I went in there I don't
know what you know what a her age were
you have a nightmare about like a
tricycle doesn't work or something so I
was like all right she just was so upset
I was like I come on right so I took it
down into the bedroom
my wife and I and she just was like
right me the old day when I was trying
to like Cleo would get up in the bed
like a [ __ ] pit bull was in the bed
moving around hitting in all this stuff
so funny my wife's like something all
right so I pick her up and I bring her
in and she has like a big-girl bed that
she's not big enough to be in yet so I
go to set her in the crib and she starts
[ __ ] crying so like all right [ __ ]
this so I put her in the big-girl bed I
go to the guest room I get the quilt and
then we lay in that I sleep next to her
but for two hours dude thrashing around
elbow and me need of the leg and all of
that stuff and at one point she was just
rubbing the top of my head and I'm
[ __ ] like trying not to laugh like
what is she doing cuz she's half-asleep
and then finally she finally fell asleep
I what killed me was I ended up sleeping
through my alarm I had to early think
cuz she has like the sound or like rain
you know the background noise or
whatever and I could I have my alarm on
load so I don't you know wake up my wife
if I have to get up early to do radio or
some [ __ ] like that so I don't but it
still [ __ ] awesome I don't know how
we got on this subject but uh being a
dad you know overrated underrated is
still underrated how [ __ ] great it is
but our twenty minutes effortless will
always be great that's question that's a
crazy under ogle don't have kids because
they always ah man it seems a lot of
work a lot of work it's like it is but
it's it's [ __ ] awesome I'm gonna say
this and also you don't have time to do
a bunch of other dumb [ __ ]
I'm
say this and I don't mean to sound
arrogant on your podcast or arrogance or
the listeners but it's like if you're
not gonna get a kid because you really
feel like you're not gonna be a good
parent I get that but to not have a kid
just because of your fears like you're
losing out on a part of life dude that I
think is [ __ ] it's unreal you know
it's it's a wit then you have there's a
weird trajectory to that life where it's
just sort of I've what I felt like all
of those years before I was a parent
that I was like you know I was like a 40
year old [ __ ] 18 year old in a way
yeah because it was just like no like a
college student who's finally moved out
from his parents house they can drink
whenever a one man I can do anything
honey and they're just like how long am
I gonna live like this Peter Pan [ __ ]
lifestyle yeah and then you know when
you have like a kid now like I kind of
love now that when I go down to a comedy
club I have this great excuse to not go
down to not hang out I mean I'm not like
I don't like hanging out with comics but
I don't want to [ __ ] get involved in
the others do some shots like I'm like I
can't yeah I can't she's coming in at
7:30 in the morning with a hominin hot
yeah she's coming out with a hot yeah
she's yeah she's coming in hot you're
tired I want breakfast I want to go
[ __ ] play t-ball and [ __ ] like that
is there like a tireless puppies that
just want to keep playing fetch you know
they just you know my kids fight sleep
and stuff I got crazy energy and I am
fine until what gets me is the bath
after dinner okay
then there's the bath and after the bath
somewhere during the bath it's just
because I'm sure in my head in my head
before the bath I'm going out I'm doing
a spot tonight blah blah blah blah by
the time she gets out of the bath and
she still has this crazy energy and I'm
trying to get her pajamas on and do all
of that [ __ ] in that and then I read her
the stories yeah all these stories by
the way that Robert McCloskey guy knows
a make way for ducklings [ __ ] one one
morning and one day in Maine well is it
the books yeah oh my god and he hadn't
wanted to put blueberries for Sal yeah
but dude those guys are just those guys
are stealing money dude who
those kid books no no these these these
are like classics
oh no but my kid my kids have like an
eight pager where it's like the geese
ate the food then Mikey was sad that the
case ate the food or the geese had
module so he went to the grocery store
and got more food for the geese then the
geese were happy Mikey and the geese had
a great day just let ya know how much
money that guy get it's like in every
school like Mikey and the geese what's
guys my wife she got a library card you
just go down and you rent two - okay why
do we keep doing this because it's what
are they gonna be [ __ ] reading that
when they're ten yeah Mikey and the
geese are you Irish German guys plow
through [ __ ] like you like you guys take
a hangover like you guys will just wake
up with a hangover that's why I like you
guys are good like dad's like dude I got
that Mediterranean I'm like dude Stacey
you gotta take this till today
Mediterranean guys you guys are too in
touch with your emotions that's why you
guys are better cooks Northern Europeans
can yeah we can there's a lot of [ __ ] we
can block out but we also suck at
cooking thanks for having me come and
see me levity live man 5th through the
8th March 5th through the 8th the Wilbur
theater June 27th one show I want to
sell in Harris you said June 27th and
you said June 17th and now June 27th I'm
sorry no Saturday June 27th 8 o'clock
Wilbur theater get tickets for that but
this weekend March 5th through the 8th W
at levity live but also Salt Lake City
Cincinnati and and Baltimore all on Paul
Versailles calm please get those tickets
and this is the best hour that I'm doing
best stuff I've ever done so come out
the nor our new specials coming out soon
quick rosy story remember that time we
were in that [ __ ] theater I'm not
going to say where it was a super old
theater and one of the guys used to be
on the road with a very famous early
rock and roller I'm not gonna say his
name either and you said to him ego this
guy was a super old guy any good man you
must had a lot of fun and he goes man we
[ __ ] them all
good oh wait a minute oh I think I know
where we were wow yeah he's like man oh
man we [ __ ] him oh yeah I mean it was
one of the things like all right no more
stories after that one I don't know what
the [ __ ] am I gonna do yeah like got it
yeah you just said yeah that was that
guy was wild all right all right dude I
gotta jump off here I got a little
[ __ ] thanks for having me man
I brother always great to see you all
right Paul virzi everybody check him out
levity live the Wilbur theater Salt Lake
City and [ __ ] Cincinnati I'll check
in on ya on Thursday